with children back in school we're
looking at what simple everyday changes
can boost their academic performance
this morning it's the topic of our
series Grand Rounds that's the practice
doctors use to teach their colleagues
about medical advances our dr. David
agus is here with some lifestyle tips
that have been scientifically proven to
help maximize a child's productivity
David good morning my kids already left
for school but what am I gonna tell them
when they get home tonight is the thing
they should be eating for breakfast
because breakfast is so important well
Nikita breakfast and by the way what's
true in kids is even more so true in us
as we've talked about it's protein and
fats so a great breakfast you know it's
breaking a fast so it's critical that we
have a good breakfast you skip that
breakfast productivity goes down eggs
hard cheeses yogurt uh great foods for
breakfast for a child and even for us so
not just a bowl of cereal make sure you
have an egg alongside that a
carbohydrate only breakfast not the best
breakfast I also thought this is
interesting too the importance of
hydration throughout the day for kids I
mean there's data that came out in a
recent study this year that when you're
dehydrated volume down in your blood you
actually don't think as well or do as
well so you want your kids to do the
best give them a glass of coconut water
a glass of water before school in during
school drink
what about exercise we know it's
important after school or at least
that's when the exercise happens whether
it's important that or not but what
about other times of the day so the data
show is that fifteen minutes of exercise
actually make a kid retain more
knowledge for five to six hours yet most
of our exercises at the end of days or
it's practice and others so you want
your kid to be the best haven't run
around the block once or twice before
they go to school it makes an impact
there are some giggles there are some
giggles in the studio about myths some
it's hard to just get them out but the
very funny thing too in the notes is I
mean is to in China of course they make
them do calisthenics before they're
doing their jumping jacks before and
because there is proven data that doing
some exercise before retains the
knowledge that you learn you want to
hear I've already house up at the bugle
I want to hear the wildest tip you know
tell anybody this but right before a
test have them do a little square of
chocolate that caffeine actually makes
them focus during a test and there's
data it improves their scores on
so we give our kids in a little plastic
bag a little square of chocolate before
they took their tests and our kids I
mean it is that to be a certain kind I
mean we use dark chocolate and you know
but listen Kit Kats my favorite but
that's a different story yes through
this loophole my kids are gonna drive
out homework though the average high
schooler spent an estimated seventeen
seventeen and a half hours per week in
homework what's the importance of down
time well that's the key is that down
time allows your brain to remember what
happened during the day so I know it
sounds counterintuitive but make them
watch TV for a little bit read a book go
for a walk and we're actually gonna
remember for that you know 20 minutes
they'll remember what happened during
the day and things will sink in if
they're working all the time
it doesn't have time to sink in that
knowledge it's critical these are good
tips for tonight there is going to be a
tough one I don't know but I mean I
obviously hear about it but it's don't
start doc yeah we'll be counseling you
is rampant in our household yeah dr.
David agus thank you good information I
don't know the protein in the morning